well good morning everyone and thank you
all for being here so bright and early
in this cold weather coming from
California 40 degrees is really really
really cold but let me greet our family
first was sitting in the front row
including my 10 year old grandson who's
going to have a real experience today
listening to great science our friends
honored guests many members of the
McGovern Institute family are all here
to attend this wonderful symposium today
it's really a day of reflection of
memory in celebration we are reflecting
on the memory of Pat McGovern who passed
away five years ago tomorrow
and it was really someone who was larger
than life
you know we remember him here as the
Mercurial co-founder of the McGovern
Institute a visionary a dreamer a doer
and someone who saw a few obstacles
nothing but opportunity and for him
there was no such thing as a glass
half-empty we all miss him and I miss
him more than you can imagine
so this international symposium is in
memory of Pat it's memorial to him so
again thank you all for being here and
I'd like to ask you let's take a moment
of silence and remember Pat in the way
we know him thank you but we also here
to celebrate because we have a lot to
celebrate a lot of achievements and
nobody would be prouder than Pat and I
can just see him you see all of you on
in it's exuberant and encouraging way in
his undying belief that the McGovern
Institute will help create a better
world and we are well on our way in the
short five year since its passing we
have made a number of significant
breakthroughs I just want to highlight a
few I mean it's a synopsis is a
shorthand description from expansion
microscopy in 2015 to the correlation
between socioeconomic status and
learning disability
and so we really need to change
socioeconomic status so we can lift
people up because figuring out we have
two learning disabilities is one but if
we can fix what the underlying causes we
will have a bigger problem in the future
then autism autism advances in 2016
showed that it might be possible not too
far into the future and I'll let you
imagine what their future might be
because it can be longer than future
implicates that we might be able to
replace a missing gene and just imagine
and what that can do for people
afflicted was such a horrible disease or
the programmable CRISPR enzyme see to
see to that targets RNA rather than DNA
which means they won't be permanent
changes to the genome everybody is so
terribly concerned about and in 2017 we
showed that the developmental brain is
organized very similarly to the adult
brain these preferences for faces and
scenes and you know in other words by
the time we are born we are already
somewhat pre-programmed for what we are
going to be or Sherlock a technique that
can revolutionize detection of cancer to
the diagnosis of infectious diseases and
once field deployable vision versions
will be available it will have
tremendous impact in major implications
for deep brain stimulation that will
eliminate surgically implanted
electrodes in think of people with
Parkinson roots or pessimism were
defined identified and a role linked to
a gene linked to a familial ALS has also
been discovered but it's bob horvitz
told me it doesn't mean we have found a
cure before the dream but that's step
one this is just as I said a shorter and
synopsis of the few really important
Greeks order X rules but in addition a
number of our own scientists have
achieved great been granted big awards
like the gadna
the breakthrough and some have been
inducted into the Academy of Sciences
also of course let's not forget the
establishment of the 10 yang Center for
autism which is a really important
addition to our Institute and then the
partnership will see at the Shenzhen
institute of advanced technologies the
tremendous partnership for our research
efforts using macaques so I really think
from my vantage point not being a
scientist we are truly on a roll and I
think we keep moving forward and it's
one person I appreciate and respect
greatly math state who's the director of
the Langley Porter Institute at UCSF and
also a scientific advisory board member
at the ten yang center said the McGovern
Institute is a gold standard everyone
aspires to be like to become so the
operative word is to inspire us so let's
people keep aspiring and never catch up
with us although we should be very
although we should be very proud of
these laudatory comments you know let's
not rest on our laurels on to the next
new thing
although pear did not witness this
progress because he's no longer with us
he will always be a looming presence and
as long as I can I will continue to
carry forward our common vision you know
and frankly I wish he was sitting right
there that's the chair he always said in
the front row bright-eyed applauding the
scientists and you know very excited of
what was possible what was to come
so let's the simple the symposium begin
and let's listen to the leading-edge
discoveries and I'm proud to turn over
the proceedings not to our current
director but to our amazing first
director Bob felt sharp bob shot Phil
sharp and you know it feel really
doesn't need an introduction to Nobel
Prize winner he's the founder of hydron
and all sorts of other great fantastic
things and we were so lucky and
fortunate to have you as our first
director for the first five years and
launch us into the right direction
so without further ado let me turn over
the proceedings to Phil but one thing
just listening you'll be enjoying the
top
[Applause]
[Music]